I spend half my time planning protest
marches and the other half argue with my
family on Facebook I feel anxious all
the time and nothing seems to help
yesterday I tried to take a cop's gun I
mean talk about stressed and I've been
drinking the sweet serenity by the
gallon and my hair still falling out and
come my afternoon chamomile but I wish
there was something stronger
there is your brand of calming herbal
tea no longer smooths out the rough
spots try the secret we English have
known about for over a century where'd
you go Oh God
you saw her too Merriweather deep dosti
it's a lovely fragrant herbal tea
concentrate that's injected directly
into your bloodstream via a small
syringe that sounds like heroin no but
nervous systems just like that I kind of
want to hear more about this deep device
simply place your teabag in a common
then when you've approximately five
millilitres of tea simply tie off your
arm with one of these Navajo ceremony or
belts provided Naveen we'll just keep
you oh okay it wouldn't be a proper
English tea without world milk and it's
it's Merriweather deep toasty
thanks to Scott Thomson for helping us
out
you
you